This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. January of 2020 marked the New York Public Library's 125th anniversary. And to celebrate, they published a list of the 10 most checked out books in the history of the library. And there's one thing about the list that you really can't help but notice right away. That's our producer Joe Rosenberg. It's made up almost entirely of children's books. So the snowy day, the cat in the hat, where the wild things are, Charlotte's web, Dan Coise is a writer at Slate.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2020年1月是纽约公共图书馆成立125周年。为了庆祝，他们发布了一份图书馆历史上借阅次数最多的10本书的名单。关于这份名单，有一点你真的会立刻注意到。那是我们的制作人乔·罗森伯格。它几乎完全由儿童读物组成。比如《戴帽子的猫》、《野兽家园》、《夏洛特的网》，丹·科伊斯是《Slate》杂志的撰稿人。
To kill a mockingbird, arguably a children's book, also on the list. Well, I mean, I like I read it as a kid, I'm not sure. Anyway. Fine, but come on Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone, the very hungry caterpillar. The only books quote unquote for adults on this list are 1984, Fahrenheit 451, and how do we friends and influence people by Dale Carnegie love that that book is still on there. All told, seven of the ten books were for kids. Taking together, they were checked out
《杀死一只知更鸟》，可以说是一本儿童读物，也在名单上。嗯，我是说，我小时候读过它，我不确定。总之。好吧，但拜托，《哈利·波特与魔法石》、《好饿的毛毛虫》。这份名单上唯一所谓的“成人”书籍是《1984》、《华氏451》和戴尔·卡内基的《人性的弱点》，很高兴这本书还在上面。总而言之，十本书中有七本是给孩子看的。加在一起，它们被借阅了
over two and a half million times. But at the very bottom of the list, Dancoise knows this little flip-out. And it just said, you know, fun fact, good night, Moon. Of course, one of the most beloved children's books of all time was not on the list. The footnote was almost like an apology, because if there's one title that you'd expect to be on the list, it's Good Night Moon. The famous picture book where the little toddler rabbit says Good Night to all the objects in its massive bedroom.
超过两百五十万次。但在名单的最底部，丹·科伊斯注意到了这个小小的脚注。上面写着，你知道，有趣的事实，《晚安，月亮》。当然，这本有史以来最受喜爱的儿童读物之一并没有出现在名单上。这个脚注几乎像是一种道歉，因为如果有一本书你期望出现在名单上，那就是《晚安，月亮》。那本著名的图画书，小兔子对它巨大卧室里的所有物体说晚安。
Good night socks, Good Night clocks, Good Night, you know, moon. I was really surprised not only because I know of its popularity, but because I have always sort of viewed it as a kind of platonically perfect children's picture book for the exact moment in the day when you most need a picture book. That moment when you need your child to fall asleep so you can finally take a shower or watch TV or do anything except parent. Still, the book had only been checked out about half as many times as the lowest ranking book on the list. But it wasn't because of lack of interest. No, it was because of one person.
晚安袜子，晚安时钟，晚安，你知道，月亮。我真的很惊讶，不仅因为我知道它的受欢迎程度，还因为我一直把它视为一种柏拉图式的完美儿童图画书，适合一天中你最需要图画书的那一刻。那一刻，你需要你的孩子入睡，这样你终于可以洗个澡、看电视或做任何除了当父母以外的事情。尽管如此，这本书的借阅次数只有名单上排名最低的书的一半左右。但这并不是因为缺乏兴趣。不，这是因为一个人。
According to the New York Public Library, an influential children's librarian at the library had disliked the story so much when it was published in 1947 that the library didn't even carry the book until 1972. And this librarian's name, according to the press release, was Anne Carroll Moore. Anne Carroll Moore was the head children's librarian at the New York Public Library for pretty much the whole first half of the 20th century. And from nearly three decades, she single-handedly kept Good Night Moon out of the entire library system. That a children's librarian could just say no New York Public Library will stock this book and the idea of children everywhere in the world growing to love Good Night Moon, except for in New York City, where they grew up sad and Good Night Moonless just seemed bananas to me.
据纽约公共图书馆称，该馆一位有影响力的儿童图书管理员在1947年该书出版时非常不喜欢这个故事，以至于图书馆直到1972年才引进这本书。根据新闻稿，这位图书管理员的名字叫安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔。安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔在20世纪上半叶的大部分时间里都是纽约公共图书馆的儿童图书管理员主管。近三十年来，她凭一己之力将《晚安，月亮》拒之于整个图书馆系统之外。一位儿童图书管理员竟然可以说“纽约公共图书馆不会收藏这本书”，而世界上各地的孩子都爱上了《晚安，月亮》，除了纽约市的孩子，他们长大后感到悲伤且没有《晚安，月亮》的陪伴，这对我来说简直太荒谬了。
Now, at this point, if you're imagining your stereotypical rule-mongering, moralizing librarian giving you the stink eye, Dancoise says, you don't need to imagine it. There are pictures. At the time that there were finally photographs on her taken, she wasn't older lady, who looked like the quintessential bun in the hair, shushing librarian, who's a really easy villain.
现在，如果你想象中那个刻板的、爱立规矩、爱说教的图书管理员正给你白眼，丹·科伊斯说，你不需要想象。有照片。在终于有人给她拍照的时候，她是一位上了年纪的女士，看起来就像那种典型的梳着发髻、嘘声不断的图书管理员，是一个非常容易塑造的反派。
But as Dan would find out, Moore was and remains a very complicated historical figure. Because long before she became a villainous banner of books, Anne Carlemore was a hero of children's literature, who left the world with one undeniably good thing. She pretty much single-handedly invented the children's library. Jullaport is a professor of history at Harvard and a staff writer for the New Yorker who wrote about Moore for the magazine. And she says that perhaps no single person has ever done more to get books into the hands of children.
但正如丹所发现的，摩尔过去是，现在仍然是一个非常复杂的历史人物。因为早在她成为臭名昭著的禁书者之前，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔就是儿童文学的英雄，她给世界留下了一件不可否认的好事。她几乎凭一己之力发明了儿童图书馆。吉尔·莱波雷是哈佛大学的历史学教授，也是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，她曾为该杂志撰写过关于摩尔的文章。她说，也许没有哪个人在让孩子接触书籍方面做得比她更多。
And she did so by creating a place for kids to read. So when you go into your neighborhood public library and there is a thing called the Children's Room and they have potted plants there and they have toys and they have a cozy rug and a rocking chair and they have story hours and they have fun art on the walls like all that stuff was invented by Anne Carole Moore. Today with all the emphasis we placed on instilling kids with love of reading. It's hard to imagine your local public library without a children's reading room. But LaPore says that before Moore came along, children weren't even allowed to enter the one place they would be sure to find a book.
她通过为孩子们创造一个阅读空间做到了这一点。所以当你走进你附近的公共图书馆，有一个叫“儿童阅览室”的地方，那里有盆栽植物，有玩具，有舒适的地毯和摇椅，有讲故事时间，墙上还有有趣的艺术品，所有这些都是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔发明的。今天，随着我们对培养孩子阅读兴趣的重视，很难想象没有儿童阅览室的当地公共图书馆。但莱波雷说，在摩尔出现之前，孩子们甚至不被允许进入他们唯一能确定找到书的地方。
Kids really couldn't go to libraries. Libraries were for grownups. The late 19th century saw some of the first public libraries being built in America. This was an age in which there was a surge in support for government-funded progressive institutions intended for the betterment of all. Or in the case of libraries, the betterment of everyone except children. You had to be, I think, 14 or 16 in most places and in most places you had to be a boy.
孩子们真的不能去图书馆。图书馆是给成年人用的。19世纪末，美国开始建造一些最早的公共图书馆。这是一个政府资助的进步机构支持激增的时代，旨在改善所有人的生活。或者在图书馆的情况下，改善除了儿童以外的所有人的生活。在大多数地方，你必须年满14或16岁，而且在大多数地方，你必须是男孩。
And the Brooklyn Public Schools had a policy that children below the third grade do not read well enough to profit from the use of library books. The thinking went that if you were too young to read, obviously there would be no need for you to go to the library. What good would that do you? And if you were old enough to read, obviously there would be no need for you to go to the library. What good would that do to you? And if you were old enough to read, but you were still a child going into a library which was full of trashy romance novels and westerns would just corrupt your mind. And so, you
布鲁克林公立学校有一项政策，认为三年级以下的孩子阅读能力不足以从图书馆书籍的使用中获益。当时的观点是，如果你太小而不会阅读，显然没有必要去图书馆。那对你有什么好处？如果你大到可以阅读，显然没有必要去图书馆。那对你有什么好处？如果你大到可以阅读，但你仍然是一个孩子，走进一个满是垃圾爱情小说和西部小说的图书馆只会腐蚀你的思想。所以，你
certainly there's no reason for you to go into a library either. Jilla Pore says that for the children of the wealthy and middle classes, who often had their own small book collections at home, being banned from libraries wasn't really a problem. But it left the children of the poor with virtually no access to literature. It's completely bound up with class discrimination, right? Because it's not really till the 1920s that you have a very strict regulation against child labor. So the children of the poor are working, like they're not reading,
当然也没有理由去图书馆。吉尔·莱波雷说，对于富裕和中产阶级的孩子来说，他们家里通常有自己的小书库，被禁止进入图书馆并不是什么大问题。但这让穷人的孩子几乎无法接触到文学。这完全与阶级歧视有关，对吧？因为直到1920年代，你才有了非常严格的反对童工的规定。所以穷人的孩子在工作，他们不读书，
they're not even learning to read. But then at the turn of this entry, Anne Carroll Moore, the crusty old librarian who hated Good Night Moon, came along and flipped the purpose of the library on its head. So I was very surprised recently to read in an article someone described her as the quintessential librarian with the bun in her hair and shushing the children when in actual fact that was exactly what she did not do. Jan Pinbarrow is an editor in children's book author and she says that in the 1890s more it was the most vocal and energetic among a small group of young progressive librarians who would be good experimenting with a radical idea.
他们甚至没有学习阅读。但在世纪之交，讨厌《晚安，月亮》的刻薄老图书管理员安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔出现了，她彻底颠覆了图书馆的目的。所以我最近读到一篇文章，有人形容她是典型的梳着发髻、对孩子嘘声不断的图书管理员，我感到非常惊讶，因为事实上她根本不是那样做的。简·平巴罗是一位编辑兼儿童书作家，她说在1890年代，摩尔是一小群年轻的进步图书管理员中最直言不讳、最有活力的人，他们当时正在尝试一个激进的想法。
What if they finally let kids into a library, stocked an area with children's books, and then made that area just for kids? And what she was trying to do, and this is what's really important, she was trying to provide a childhood to working-class kids. She was trying to give them all the luxury and leisure of having a space with books that are made for them to be able to read so that they would have what we would think of now as, you know, a way to address an achievement gap. And she was trying
如果他们最终让孩子们进入图书馆，在区域内储备儿童书籍，并使该区域专供儿童使用会怎样？她试图做的事情，这一点非常重要，是试图为工人阶级的孩子提供童年。她试图给他们所有拥有为他们制作的书籍的空间的奢侈和闲暇，让他们能够阅读，这样他们就会拥有我们现在认为的，你知道，解决成就差距的方法。她试图
to level that field. And in 1906, more got the chance to run this experiment on an unrivaled scale. The New York Public Library was building its iconic main branch at the corner of 42nd Street in Fifth Avenue, and it would feature a dedicated children's reading room that would be designed, stocked, and run by more. And there are just these incredible photographs of that children's room when it opened in 1911.
去拉平那个领域。1906年，摩尔有机会在无与伦比的规模上进行这项实验。纽约公共图书馆正在第42街和第五大道交汇处建造其标志性的主馆，它将设有一个专门的儿童阅览室，由摩尔设计、储备和管理。当那个儿童阅览室在1911年开放时，有一些令人难以置信的照片。
The photo's depict one of the earliest public spaces designed exclusively for kids. More started by borrowing the idea of kid-sized tables and chairs from kindergarten. But she took the concept even further. She had benches, windows seats, built at the bottoms of the windows, giant windows, but they're like pint-sized. Like if you were five years old, you could sit in those window seats and your feet would touch the floor.
照片描绘了最早专为儿童设计的公共空间之一。摩尔首先借鉴了幼儿园儿童尺寸桌椅的想法。但她把这个概念推得更远。她在窗户底部建造了长凳和窗座，巨大的窗户，但它们是小型的。就像如果你五岁，你可以坐在那些窗座上，你的脚会碰到地板。
More especially wanted to provide poor kids from the tenements, access to the beauty of the natural world. So she installed pink floor tiles to catch the light coming through the windows and then filled the room with shell collections, butterflies, and dozens of bowls of freshly cut flowers. And these children, a lot of them were stark for nature.
摩尔特别想为来自廉租房的贫困儿童提供接触自然世界之美的机会。所以她安装了粉红色的地砖来捕捉穿过窗户的光线，然后在房间里摆满了贝壳收藏、蝴蝶和几十碗鲜切花。这些孩子，他们中的许多人对自然非常渴望。
And they would line up for the chance to look at and smell the flowers when she brought them in. More took down the silent signs. The library was now a space for puppet shows and musical performances and story hours, featuring stories in multiple languages, so that the children of immigrants who deny it read or speak English would still feel welcome.
当她把花带进来时，他们会排队等待看花和闻花香的机会。摩尔取下了“保持安静”的标志。图书馆现在是一个举办木偶戏、音乐表演和讲故事时间的空间，故事以多种语言呈现，这样那些不会读或说英语的移民孩子也会感到受欢迎。
But most importantly, more filled the shelves of the new reading room, with hundreds and eventually thousands of children's books, not locked in a cabinet or in a rich kid's nursery, but out in the open for any child to pick up, leave through, and read. And if a child liked the expensive book they were holding, they could take it home. The only requirement was that they signed their name in a big black ledger alongside a pledge. When I write my name in this book, I promise to take good care of the books I use in the library and at home and to obey the rules of the library. And it was a kind of sanctified moment.
但最重要的是，摩尔在新阅览室的书架上摆满了数百甚至数千本儿童读物，不是锁在柜子里或富家孩子的托儿所里，而是放在开放的地方，供任何孩子拿取、翻阅和阅读。如果孩子喜欢他们手里拿着的昂贵的书，他们可以把它带回家。唯一的要求是他们在黑色大账本上签下自己的名字，并附上一份誓言。当我在这本书上写下我的名字时，我承诺会好好爱护我在图书馆和家里使用的书籍，并遵守图书馆的规则。这是一种神圣的时刻。
The pledge turned the process of checking out a book into a child's first act of citizenship. The room was an overnight success. Rich and poor kids alike flocked to the library. And more began training librarians to establish new reading rooms throughout New York, including Nella Larson, the prominent African American writer who created the first children's room in Harlem.
这份誓言将借书的过程变成了孩子作为公民的第一次行动。这个房间一夜之间就成功了。富裕和贫穷的孩子们都涌向图书馆。摩尔开始培训图书管理员在纽约各地建立新的阅览室，包括杰出的非裔美国作家内拉·拉森，她在哈莱姆区创建了第一个儿童阅览室。
By 1913, just two years after the children's room opened, Mora could boast that one third of the volumes borrowed from the city's branch libraries were children's books. And children's rooms were springing up even more quickly in the rest of the country. By the end of the 1920s, by one estimate, there were perhaps as many as 1,500 children's rooms were sprained up even more quickly in the rest of the country. By the end of the 1920s, by one estimate, there were perhaps as many as 1,500 children's rooms in the US alone. And her reach was really worldwide, and there are places and countries where people would say, well, if you walk into that library, you'll realize that that was touched by Anne Carole Moore. The spread of Moore's reading remodel was also instrumental in establishing children's literature
到1913年，也就是儿童阅览室开放仅两年后，摩尔就可以自豪地说，从城市分馆借出的书籍中，三分之一是儿童读物。儿童阅览室在全国其他地区涌现得更快。到1920年代末，据估计，仅在美国就有多达1500个儿童阅览室。她的影响力确实是全球性的，在一些地方和国家，人们会说，如果你走进那个图书馆，你会意识到那是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔触及过的地方。摩尔阅读模式的传播在确立儿童文学方面也起到了重要作用
as literature. Moore convinced the library going public that books like the Velveteen Rabbit, Winnie the Pooh, and the works of Beatrix Potter were in fact art. In the 1920s, saw an explosion in dedicated children's departments at major publishers, and prizes like the Newbury Medal, which more helped create.
作为文学。摩尔说服了去图书馆的公众，像《绒布兔子》、《小熊维尼》和碧翠丝·波特的作品实际上是艺术。1920年代，主要出版商的专门儿童部门出现了爆炸式增长，像纽伯瑞奖这样的奖项也随之诞生，摩尔参与了该奖项的创建。
So, for multiple generations of New York children, Anne Carole Moore was the reason that the libraries became places that fostered their love of storytelling and love of books. But all this came with a crucial caveat, which is that Anne Carole Moore's vision was never limited to simply creating a place for kids to read.
因此，对于几代纽约儿童来说，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔是图书馆成为培养他们对讲故事和书籍热爱的地方的原因。但这一切都有一个关键的警告，那就是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的愿景从未局限于仅仅为孩子们创造一个阅读的地方。
From the beginning, it was also about what counted as children's literature. So even as she was letting more children than ever into the library, Moore was keeping all kinds of books out. And as the head of the children's department in the New York Public Library, she was in charge of choosing the books that the children's departments of all those libraries acquired. And the NYPL's purchases often set the standard for libraries nationwide. Back then, children's titles were only published once a year in fall. So every year, around the same time, more would make a list of her favorite upcoming books.
从一开始，它也关乎什么才算儿童文学。所以，即使她让比以往任何时候都多的孩子进入图书馆，摩尔也把各种各样的书拒之门外。作为纽约公共图书馆儿童部的主管，她负责选择所有这些图书馆的儿童部所采购的书籍。而纽约公共图书馆的采购往往为全国的图书馆设定了标准。那时，儿童读物每年只在秋季出版一次。所以每年，在同一时间，摩尔都会列出一份她最喜欢的即将出版的书籍清单。
And that list was used by other librarians across the country. So if you ran a library in Dubuque, Iowa, and you were trying to figure out, well, what am I going to spend my budget on? You just go right down the list and go, I'm going to buy one of this, two of this, three of this, one of this, oh, none of this, whatever. You would use that list to guide your purchasing? More also had a regular review column. The parents and librarians alike used to decide which books were worth buying and which
那份清单被全国各地的其他图书管理员使用。所以如果你在爱荷华州迪比克经营一家图书馆，你正试图弄清楚，好吧，我要把预算花在什么上？你只需顺着清单看，说，我要买一本这个，两本这个，三本这个，一本这个，哦，不要这个，随便。你会用那份清单来指导你的采购吗？摩尔还有一个定期的评论专栏。家长和图书管理员都用它来决定哪些书值得买，哪些
weren't. So, she's the most eminent children's book reviewer in the country, but then because she was also the chief purchaser for books, she quickly accumulates really far too much power. At the height of her career in the 1920s and 30s, she was like the Anna Win-Tor of Kids Lit. Editors and authors were routinely seen walking up the steps of the public library's main branch between the two marble lions to drop off their books and await Moore's verdict.
不值得。所以，她是全国最杰出的儿童书评论家，但因为她也是书籍的首席采购员，她很快积累了太多的权力。在1920和30年代她职业生涯的巅峰时期，她就像儿童文学界的安娜·温图尔。编辑和作者经常被看到走上公共图书馆主馆的台阶，穿过两只大理石狮子，放下他们的书，等待摩尔的裁决。
If they were lucky, she'd send back notes for suggested changes, which they would doodfully incorporate into the final draft. Others weren't so fortunate. The story about Anne Carole Morrell, though no one, including her biographers, knows whether this was apocryphal or not, was that she actually had a custom made rubber stamp
如果他们幸运的话，她会寄回建议修改的笔记，他们会恭敬地将其纳入最终草稿。其他人就没有那么幸运了。关于安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的故事，虽然没有人，包括她的传记作者，知道这是否是杜撰的，是她实际上有一个定制的橡皮图章
that read, not recommended for purchase by expert. And that if she didn't like your book, she would stamp that on your book. And you, that's it, your book's dead. No one's gonna order your book, better luck next time it, your book's dead. No one's going to order your book. Better luck next time. And there were a lot of manuscripts not recommended for purchase by expert, because Anne Caromore had very specific tastes in children's literature.
上面写着“专家不建议购买”。如果她不喜欢你的书，她就会在你的书上盖上那个章。然后，就这样，你的书完了。没有人会订购你的书，下次好运。有很多手稿被“专家不建议购买”，因为安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔对儿童文学有着非常具体的品味。
She may have been a great advocate of children's books as art, but in her zeal to protect kids from the horrors of poverty and urban life, more almost invariably favored magical once upon a time stories that felt pastoral and tweey. The whole point was for them to take the less fortunate into their warm, bougie embrace. So her favorite children's books, the ones that she approved, certainly weren't meant to represent anything that a child might actually see or experience in his or her everyday life. They were meant to be little mini escapes into this magical world of talking animals and rabbits and waste coats and whatnot. To be honest, this is kind of where most of my experts for this story
她可能是一位伟大的儿童文学艺术倡导者，但在她保护孩子免受贫困和城市生活恐怖的热情中，摩尔几乎总是偏爱那些感觉田园诗般、矫揉造作的魔法“很久很久以前”的故事。重点是让他们把不幸的人带入他们温暖、资产阶级式的怀抱。所以她最喜欢的儿童读物，那些她认可的，肯定不是为了代表孩子在日常生活中可能实际看到或经历的任何事情。它们是为了成为进入这个充满会说话的动物、兔子、背心等等的魔法世界的小型逃避。老实说，这就是我这个故事的大多数专家
get off the end-carol more train. Like, she was a sharp-eyed critic. it's just it's not my eye so I'm trying to be charitable here, say like you know like she likes gooey and she likes super sweet and she likes silly animals that talk. Because one of the poo is great right? But for a few decades of children's literature from the 19 teens to the 1920s pretty much everything coming out of the publishers was very poo. Meanwhile, there were almost no books for kids that took place in cities, no books for kids
下安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔这趟车的地方。就像，她是一位目光敏锐的评论家。这只是，这不是我的眼光，所以我试图在这里宽容一点，说，你知道，她喜欢粘糊糊的，她喜欢超级甜的，她喜欢会说话的傻动物。因为《小熊维尼》很棒，对吧？但在1910年代到1920年代的几十年儿童文学中，出版商出版的几乎所有东西都非常“维尼”。与此同时，几乎没有关于城市中发生的儿童读物，没有关于
that depicted real-world problems, and very few children's books containing messy ideas or ambiguous endings. Stories with those qualities never made it past more. Although sometimes a book could meet all of more criteria, and she would still have it killed, for reasons known only to her. Do you think more, you said she's a pretty sharp-eyed critic. Do you think she had a kind of systematized notion of her own gay keeping rules, or was she just like shooting from the hip. You know, I have no idea.
描绘现实世界问题的儿童读物，也很少有包含混乱想法或模棱两可结局的儿童读物。具有这些品质的故事从未通过摩尔这一关。虽然有时一本书可以满足摩尔的所有标准，但她仍然会因为只有她自己知道的原因将其扼杀。你认为摩尔，你说她是一位目光敏锐的评论家。你认为她对自己的把关规则有一种系统化的概念，还是她只是随心所欲？你知道，我不知道。
I think she was drunk with power. Like I think she loved being the lady in charge. Like I think she just loved having the entire publishing industry at her back in call. And she thinks she's right. And she has no doubts about it. Like she thinks she's right. But even as Anne Carroll Moore held the publishing world in her iron grip, a small group of preschool teachers were busy writing stories for kids that embodied everything in children's
我认为她被权力冲昏了头脑。就像我认为她喜欢成为负责人的女士。就像我认为她只是喜欢让整个出版业随叫随到。而且她认为她是正确的。她对此毫无疑问。就像她认为她是正确的。但即使安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔以铁腕控制着出版界，一小群学前班老师正忙着为孩子们写故事，这些故事体现了儿童文学中摩尔所憎恨的一切。
literature that Moore hated. Their stories would go on to influence an entire generation of children's book authors. And they worked just a few blocks away at an experimental school in Greenwich Village, called Bank Street. Bank Street came along and said that picture books ought to be stories about modern urban life. Leonard Marcus is a historian of children's literature.
他们的故事将继续影响整整一代儿童书作者。他们就在几个街区外，在格林威治村的一所实验学校工作，名叫“银行街”。银行街出现并说图画书应该是关于现代城市生活的故事。伦纳德·马库斯是一位儿童文学历史学家。
And he says that the Bank Street Cooperative School for Student Teachers, founded by the great educational reformer Lucy's Prague Mitchell, was in many ways the ancestor of today's progressive schools. They believed that teachers should let children guide their own learning experience. And it just so happened that when people trained as teachers at Backstreet, they didn't read textbooks. They were trying to write stories for children so that future teachers would really know from their own experience what kinds of stories are meaningful to kids stories for children. So the future teachers would really know from their own
他说，由伟大的教育改革家露西·斯普拉格·米切尔创立的银行街学生教师合作学校，在许多方面是今天进步学校的祖先。他们认为老师应该让孩子引导他们自己的学习体验。碰巧的是，当人们在银行街接受教师培训时，他们不读教科书。他们试图为孩子们写故事，这样未来的老师就能真正从他们自己的经验中知道什么样的故事对孩子有意义。所以未来的老师就能真正从他们自己的
experience what kinds of stories are meaningful to kids at different ages. And when the teachers tried to write stories for the youngest kids at Bank Street, they noticed something important. Children are interested in the world they find themselves in. Certainly there are children who have flights of fancy and think about dragons and wizards and whatnot. But anyone who's had a four-year-old knows that often the thing that is most interesting to them is the garbage truck that comes by every Tuesday afternoon. So instead of a book about magical realms, a book published by Bank Street would be about the child's more immediate world, focusing on the kinds of things that small children
经验中知道什么样的故事对不同年龄的孩子有意义。当老师们试图为银行街最小的孩子写故事时，他们注意到了一些重要的事情。孩子们对他们所处的环境感兴趣。当然，有些孩子有奇思妙想，会想到龙、巫师之类的东西。但任何带过四岁孩子的人都知道，对他们来说最有趣的事情往往是每周二下午经过的垃圾车。所以，银行街出版的书不是关于魔法领域的书，而是关于孩子更直接的世界，专注于小孩子在城市里
in cities really, really like, like street cars and a trip to the grocery store and steam shovels. Designed for the very young, these stories rarely had plots. They were more like games, circular, interactive and open-ended. Plot wasn't the most important thing at Bank Street. Much more important was being invited to participate. Bank Street stories might depict a jackhammer or a train going by and then ask the child to imitate those sounds, but also any other sounds they might feel like imitating. Giving the child an opening to expand them, you know, infinitely, if they wanted to, not just sit there and listen to the once upon a time story. All of which pretty much stood in diametric opposition to the philosophy of Ancaro Mor.
真正非常喜欢的那些东西，比如电车、去杂货店和蒸汽铲。这些故事专为极年幼的孩子设计，很少有情节。它们更像游戏，循环的、互动的和开放式的。情节在银行街并不是最重要的。更重要的是被邀请参与。银行街的故事可能会描绘一个手提钻或经过的火车，然后要求孩子模仿那些声音，但也包括他们可能想模仿的任何其他声音。给孩子一个扩展他们的空间，你知道，如果他们想的话，无限地，不仅仅是坐在那里听“很久很久以前”的故事。所有这些几乎与安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的哲学截然相反。
The idea that the everyday life of a child with no magic whatsoever involved in it is something that ought to be immortalized in a children's book. Definitely was not Ancaro Mor's speed. To more, these plotless games for the very young, with their emphasis on experience over imagination, simply didn't count as literature. She made sure they weren't included in her annual list of best books.
孩子没有任何魔法的日常生活是应该在儿童读物中永垂不朽的东西。这绝对不是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的风格。对摩尔来说，这些为极年幼孩子准备的无情节游戏，强调体验胜过想象力，根本算不上文学。她确保它们没有被列入她的年度最佳书籍清单。
She didn't even dain't write her usual scathing review. In the very first Bank Street books, I'll be here in now series, stayed off the library shelves. But Bank Street's earliest stories had another more fundamental problem. I think the stories in the first year now book, they're boring. Mac Barnett is the author of over 40 children's books. And he says that from the point of view of craft, which is to say, of actually capturing
她甚至不屑于写她通常的尖刻评论。第一批银行街书籍，《此时此地》系列，被挡在了图书馆书架之外。但银行街最早的故事还有另一个更根本的问题。我认为《此时此地》书中的故事很无聊。麦克·巴内特是40多本儿童读物的作者。他说，从工艺的角度来看，也就是真正吸引孩子注意力的角度来看，银行街对儿童文学的最初尝试是糟糕的。
a kid's attention, Bank Street's first attempts at children's literature were terrible. Although they were new at the time and feel sort of radical, they are being written according to a formula. You can see the philosophy, they're theory driven. The writing in most of these early stories came across as stiff and formulaic. There were only occasional illustrations with no real interplay between image and words. And every story started with an introduction describing his pedagogical intent. Here's one from a chapter called The Sky Scraper.
虽然它们在当时是新的，感觉有点激进，但它们是按照公式编写的。你可以看到其中的哲学，它们是理论驱动的。这些早期故事中的大多数写作显得生硬且公式化。只有偶尔的插图，图像和文字之间没有真正的互动。每个故事都以介绍其教学意图的导言开头。这是其中一个章节，名为《摩天大楼》。
The story tries to assemble into a related form, many facts well known to seven-year-olds and to present the whole as a modern industrial process. So like, right there, like, as soon as your story begins with a mission statement, it's already over. Like, the thing is lying on the floor. The writers at Bank Street were just as blinded by their own dogma, as Anne Carole Moore,
这个故事试图将七岁孩子熟知的许多事实组合成一种相关的形式，并将整体呈现为一个现代工业过程。所以，就像，就在那里，就像，一旦你的故事以使命宣言开始，它就已经结束了。就像，东西躺在地板上。银行街的作家们和安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔一样被他们自己的教条所蒙蔽，
and with the same end result. Their stories could never achieve their high-minded aspirations, because they felt stale and doctrinaire. But in the 1930s, one person managed to make the Bank Street style come alive. The future author of Good Night Moon. Margaret Wise Brown was a teacher at Bank Street who didn't want to be a teacher. She wanted to be a famous literary writer. She wanted her short stories to be published in the New Yorker,
结果也一样。他们的故事永远无法实现他们高尚的愿望，因为它们感觉陈旧且教条。但在1930年代，一个人成功地让银行街风格活了起来。未来的《晚安，月亮》作者。玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗是银行街的一名老师，她不想当老师。她想成为一名著名的文学作家。她想让她的短篇小说在《纽约客》上发表，
but that wasn't going to happen. And honestly, neither was the teaching thing. Like all of her evaluations say, like, you know, she's, I don't think she's going to be a great teacher. So she couldn't write for adults and she couldn't teach kids. But when Margaret Wise Brown tried to write Bank Street stories for kids, something weird happened. They were good. In Brown's hands, these stories for the very young, with their circular rhythms and game-like structures, were transformed into something new.
但这不会发生。老实说，教学的事情也不会。就像她所有的评估都说，你知道，她，我不认为她会成为一名伟大的老师。所以她不能为成年人写作，也不能教孩子。但当玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗试图为孩子写银行街故事时，奇怪的事情发生了。它们很好。在布朗手中，这些为极年幼孩子准备的故事，以其循环的节奏和游戏般的结构，被转化为新的东西。
The big bank street realization, I think, from Margot Liesbrown, is that through talking to kids, she discovered her purpose as a writer because she found that kids are the best audience for poetry. Margot Lies Brown's books were more than stories or games. They were poems for children who were still open to novel ways of seeing and describing the world around them. Consider a story from a series of books Brown first started in collaboration with Bankstreet, the noisy books.
银行街的大发现，我认为，对于玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗来说，是通过与孩子交谈，她发现了自己作为作家的目的，因为她发现孩子是诗歌最好的听众。玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗的书不仅仅是故事或游戏。它们是为那些仍然对看待和描述周围世界的新颖方式持开放态度的孩子准备的诗歌。考虑一下布朗最初与银行街合作开始的一系列书籍中的一个故事，《吵闹书》。
The story is about a little dog who hears a tiny, almost imperceptible noise and tries to identify it. Brown asked the reader to guess what the sound might be, but instead of suggesting things that we might think of as making sounds, she points to things that don't. So it says, was it butter, melting? Was it a little blue flower growing? Was it a skyscraper scraping the sky? The early Bank Street books would have simply asked the reader to register that a skyscraper was tall, but Brown was encouraging them to perceive it in an entirely new poetic fashion.
故事是关于一只小狗，它听到一个微小的、几乎察觉不到的声音，并试图识别它。布朗要求读者猜测那可能是什么声音，但她没有建议我们认为会发出声音的东西，而是指出了那些不会发出声音的东西。所以它说，是黄油融化的声音吗？是蓝色小花生长的声音吗？是摩天大楼刮擦天空的声音吗？早期的银行街书籍只会要求读者登记摩天大楼很高，但布朗鼓励他们以一种全新的诗意方式去感知它。
Sky-Scriper scraping the sky and suddenly you can hear it. Brown was also a master of writing poetry that worked in tandem with the art in a book, particularly by deploying page turns. Your average contemporary children's picture book will contain 14 page turns, and most authors will use these moments to build suspense. If you wanna know what happens, you gotta turn the page. But Markerwise Brown's page turns, just as often zigzag, setting up patterns
摩天大楼刮擦天空，突然你可以听到它了。布朗也是编写与书中艺术协同工作的诗歌的大师，特别是通过运用翻页。你普通的当代儿童图画书将包含14次翻页，大多数作者会利用这些时刻来建立悬念。如果你想知道发生了什么，你必须翻页。但玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗的翻页，同样经常呈之字形，建立模式
and then breaking them. So you get, was it an ant crawling? Was it a B wondering? Page turn. Was it an elephant tiptoeing down the stairs? And you move across that page turn from this very intimate domestic scene of a dog, very small on the page listening at the stairs, to this giant two-page spread, this elephant, and the scale is gigantic. He barely fits in the frame. Pages turns like these can be disorienting,
然后打破它们。所以你得到，是蚂蚁在爬吗？是蜜蜂在想吗？翻页。是大象在楼梯上踮着脚尖走吗？你穿过那个翻页，从这只狗非常亲密的家庭场景，在页面上非常小，在楼梯上听着，到这个巨大的双页跨页，这只大象，比例是巨大的。他几乎装不进框架。像这样的翻页可能会让人迷失方向，
and that's the point. You feel like you're constantly crashing into new worlds and discovering new things, which, again, like that's what being a kid feels like a lot of the time. Brown also helped change the look and feel of children's books. As an editor at Scott Publishing, a small imprint associated with Fang Street, she developed one of the first tactile books featuring lambs with real toy bells and bunnies with real cottonball
这就是重点。你感觉自己不断地撞进新的世界，发现新的东西，这，再次，就像那是作为孩子大部分时间的感觉。布朗还帮助改变了儿童读物的外观和感觉。作为斯科特出版社的编辑，这是一个与银行街相关的小出版公司，她开发了最早的触觉书籍之一，特色是带有真正玩具铃铛的羔羊和带有真正棉球尾巴的兔子，
tails, turning the book into a physically interactive object. But perhaps Margaret Wise Brown's greatest accomplishment was bridging the divide between the two factions of children's literature. Her stories provided the interactive experiences focusing on everyday things, but they also contained elements like talking animals, and they weren't afraid to lean into nostalgia and whimsy. So instead of rejecting the documentary realism of Bank Street or the magical escapism of Anker Almore, Brown found a way to combine them. And nowhere did she do this better than in Good Night Moon.
将书变成了一个物理上的互动对象。但也许玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗最大的成就是弥合了儿童文学两个派系之间的鸿沟。她的故事提供了专注于日常事物的互动体验，但它们也包含了像会说话的动物这样的元素，而且它们不害怕倾向于怀旧和奇思妙想。所以，布朗没有拒绝银行街的纪录片现实主义或安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的魔法逃避主义，而是找到了一种结合它们的方法。在《晚安，月亮》中，她做得最好。
For Good Night Moon, Brown took inspiration from something in her own daily life. Whenever she woke up feeling sad, and struggled to get out of bed, she'd perform a kind of ritual. She would line bed and look around and focus on different objects in the room that she was glad to have in her presence and would essentially count her blessings. She would take in the books on her shelf, the pattern of her sheets, the view from her window, and then when she was finished, she would write it all down in a list. Get up and face the day. For Good Night Moon, Brown simply reversed the ritual. It's a list you read to fall asleep.
对于《晚安，月亮》，布朗从她自己日常生活中的某件事中获得了灵感。每当她醒来感到悲伤，挣扎着起床时，她就会进行一种仪式。她会躺在床上，环顾四周，专注于房间里她很高兴拥有的不同物体，本质上是在数她的祝福。她会吸收书架上的书、床单的图案、窗外的景色，然后当她完成后，她会把这一切写成清单。起床面对这一天。对于《晚安，月亮》，布朗只是反转了这个仪式。这是一份你读着入睡的清单。
What are we gonna read today? Good Night Moon. The beginning of Good Night Moon really is nothing more than a list. Documenting the objects in the bedroom of a little bunny getting ready to go to sleep. In the great green room there was a telephone and a red balloon and a picture of... there's no plot, no tension, just things. The cow jumping over the moon. But then you move into the second section, unannounced. Good night bears, good night chairs. And yet everyone knows what to do when they get there.
我们今天要读什么？《晚安，月亮》。《晚安，月亮》的开头确实不过是一份清单。记录了一个准备睡觉的小兔子的卧室里的物体。在那个大大的绿色房间里，有一部电话，一个红气球，还有一张……的照片。没有情节，没有紧张感，只有东西。牛跳过月亮。但随后你进入了第二部分，没有预告。晚安熊，晚安椅子。然而每个人都知道到达那里时该做什么。
Good night kittens. Which is chime in. And good night mittens. Right. What about this one next to it? And then you come to the page that says goodnight nobody nobody what do you do with that and it's up to the child to decide and that's pure bank street and I would say pure magic and Ann Carole Moore hated it. Oh, yeah, she hated it.
晚安小猫。也就是跟着念。还有晚安手套。对。旁边这个呢？然后你翻到写着“晚安，没人”的那一页，没人，你对此做什么？这取决于孩子来决定，那是纯粹的银行街风格，我会说是纯粹的魔法，而安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔讨厌它。哦，是的，她讨厌它。
Yeah, she was totally opposed to it. By the time Good Night Moon came out in 1947, Moore was technically retired from her job at the library. But even in retirement, she remained in control of the children's department, showing up at meetings uninvited and making sure her policies remained in place. Even when her successor would like to try to change the meeting room at the last minute, Anne Caromore was still just magically show up and run that meeting.
是的，她完全反对它。《晚安，月亮》在1947年出版时，摩尔在技术上已经从图书馆的工作中退休了。但即使在退休后，她仍然控制着儿童部，不请自来地出现在会议上，并确保她的政策保持不变。即使当她的继任者想在最后一刻改变会议室时，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔仍然会神奇地出现并主持那个会议。
Leonard Marcus says we know what more thought of Good Night Moon, because the New York Public Library maintained internal reviews of every book that was submitted to them. And I was secretly shown the report on Good Night Moon, secretly because nobody outside of the library staff was ever supposed to see them, but I found someone who's willing to leak the report to me.
伦纳德·马库斯说，我们知道摩尔对《晚安，月亮》的看法，因为纽约公共图书馆保留了提交给他们的每一本书的内部评论。我被秘密地展示了关于《晚安，月亮》的报告，秘密是因为图书馆工作人员以外的任何人都不应该看到它们，但我找到了一个愿意把报告泄露给我的人。
The report described Good Night Moon as an unbearably sentimental piece of work. Which is just funny when I think of unbearable sentimentality as like the jacket copy of a book you write for Anne Carole Moore. But it didn't matter. Good Night Moon had the stink of Bank Street on it. The book was not recommended for purchase by expert. Good Night Moon sold only a handful of copies before more or less disappearing from stores.
报告将《晚安，月亮》描述为一部令人难以忍受的感伤作品。这很有趣，因为我认为令人难以忍受的感伤就像你为安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔写的书的封底文案。但这并不重要。《晚安，月亮》身上有银行街的臭味。这本书被“专家不建议购买”。《晚安，月亮》在几乎从商店消失之前只卖出了几本。
Marrow has browned, not only a few years later, in 1952, following complications from a surgery. She was just 42 years old. But even if she didn't know it, it was right around this time that Good Night Moon's fortune to begin to change. It was the era of the baby boom. Pop psychology was in, and parents eager to raise their children
玛格丽特·怀斯·布朗在几年后的1952年去世了，手术并发症。她才42岁。但即使她不知道，就在这个时候，《晚安，月亮》的命运开始改变。那是婴儿潮时代。流行心理学很流行，父母渴望用最新的方法抚养孩子，
using the latest methods, devoured books and articles about what children needed at various stages of life. And in 1951 there was the column saying that if you have a two-year-old and he is not going to sleep, read them this book, Good Night Moon, it'll work. And sure enough, 1951 is when sales of Good Nightmoon at bookstores slowly began to rise. And that book was read by kids in the late 50s who grew into adults, who remembered reading that book more than any other book, so bought it for their own kids, who then grew into adults, who loved that book more than any other, and that's how it happened. It happened in a way that maybe is most terrifying to An Carol Moore. An Carol Moore is sort of irrelevant to the success of that book.
贪婪地阅读关于孩子在生命各个阶段需要什么的各种书籍和文章。1951年有一篇专栏说，如果你有一个两岁的孩子，他睡不着觉，读这本书给他听，《晚安，月亮》，它会起作用。果然，1951年是《晚安，月亮》在书店的销量开始缓慢上升的时候。那本书被50年代末的孩子们读过，他们长大成人，比任何其他书都更记得读过那本书，所以为他们自己的孩子买了它，他们后来长大成人，比任何其他书都更爱那本书，事情就是这样发生的。它发生的某种方式可能是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔最害怕的。安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔对那本书的成功某种程度上是无关紧要的。
In 1972, the New York Public Library caved and finally put Good Night Moon on the shelves. At that point, it was selling nearly 100,000 copies a year. As of 2017, it sold nearly 48 million. Leonard Marcus says that Clement Heard, the illustrator of Good Night Moon, showed him a fan letter once. He was from a mother whose little boy had wanted the book red to him every night, six times, from start to finish. And one night after the sixth reading, she laid the book down on his bed, and he stood up. It was open to a page with one of the color, full color illustrations of the room. And he put his foot down on the page,
1972年，纽约公共图书馆屈服了，终于把《晚安，月亮》放在了书架上。那时，它每年销售近10万册。截至2017年，它销售了近4800万册。伦纳德·马库斯说，《晚安，月亮》的插画家克莱门特·赫德曾经给他看了一封粉丝信。那是来自一位母亲，她的小男孩想让她每晚给他读这本书，六次，从头到尾。有一天晚上，在第六次阅读后，她把书放在他的床上，他站了起来。它翻开到一页，上面有房间的全彩插图之一。他把脚放在页面上，
and then he burst into tears. His mother didn't know what to make of it, so she just waited to see what would happen next. And then he put his second foot down and just completely melted down. And then she realized what was happening. And she wrote to him and said, my son wanted to, was trying to climb inside your room.
然后他大哭起来。他的母亲不知道该怎么办，所以她只是等着看接下来会发生什么。然后他放下了第二只脚，完全崩溃了。然后她意识到发生了什么。她写信给他，说，我的儿子想，试图爬进你的房间。
That's how real it is to him. Jillipore said she also came across a letter. But this one was about Anne Carroll Moore. Moore died in 1961. And upon hearing of her death, a prominent editor wrote to a friend, quote, much as she did for children's books, I can't help feeling her influence
对他来说，这就是现实。吉利·波尔说她也偶然发现了一封信。但这封信是关于安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的。摩尔于1961年去世。在得知她去世的消息后，一位著名的编辑写信给朋友说：“尽管她为儿童读物做了很多贡献，但我还是忍不住觉得她的影响
was baleful on the whole. Am I wrong? It's an incredibly powerful, I mean, final epitaph on her life. I, I, it seems totally fair to me. She did an extraordinary amount for children's literature and for children early on, and then I think she kind of lost her grip. Lapor, however, is also quick to defend more. And so is Dan Coise. Walk into the children's reading room of any library in the country at story time, he says.
总的来说是灾难性的。我错了吗？我的意思是，这是对她一生极其有力，甚至是最终的墓志铭。我，我，我觉得这对我来说完全公平。她在早期为儿童文学和儿童做了非凡的贡献，然后我认为她有点失去了控制。然而，拉波尔也很快为摩尔辩护。丹·科伊斯也是如此。他说，在全国任何一家图书馆的儿童阅览室里，在讲故事的时候走进去，
And you're witnessing her contribution. The notion that the library's mission remains to serve children and to make them feel at home in the space and to make them feel like reading is a thing for them is remarkable. And I don't want a lose sight of that. And for all her faults and flaws, that's because of her. If you go back and look at the list of the New York Public Library's top 10
你就能见证她的贡献。图书馆的使命仍然是服务儿童，让他们在这个空间里感到宾至如归，让他们觉得阅读是属于他们的，这种观念是了不起的。我不想忽视这一点。尽管她有种种缺点和瑕疵，但那都是因为她。如果你回去看看纽约公共图书馆的前十名
checked out books, a lot of the titles are ones more probably would have banned that she's still been around. After all, where the wild things are, the snowy day, the very hungry caterpillar, they all owe something to the work of Market Wise Brown and the teachers at Bankstreet. But the fact that the top ten list is mostly children's books in the first place, that's something we owe to Anne Carole Moore. books in the first place, that's something we owe to Anne Carole Moore. Next up, the story of a doll that delighted children and possibly terrified adults at the New York Public Library. After this.
借阅书籍，很多书名如果她还在世的话，很可能会被她禁掉。毕竟，《野兽家园》、《下雪天》、《好饿的毛毛虫》，它们都归功于玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗和银行街学校老师们的工作。但首先，前十名榜单主要是儿童读物，这要归功于安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔。接下来，是一个在纽约公共图书馆让孩子们高兴，可能也让大人们感到恐惧的玩偶的故事。稍后回来。
Okay, so I'm here with Joe Rosenberg. So one of the reasons why we invented this little code of section is there's often little outtakes from the story that we couldn't quite fit in. And I hear you have some really good bonus material for me. Yeah. And I wanted to save it for the code up because it is the one subplot in this whole saga that is maybe the thing I most wanted to talk about. But if we talked about it in the main piece,
好的，我和乔·罗森伯格在一起。我们发明这个小栏目的原因之一是，故事中经常有一些我们无法完全放进去的小花絮。我听说你有一些非常好的额外素材给我。是的。我想把它留到栏目里，因为这是整个传奇中唯一一个我最想谈论的子情节。但如果我们把它放在主篇里，
it would just derail the story. Like it would just bring the entire story to a crashing hole. I know exactly what you mean, I've totally been there. Yeah, yeah, and it's because whenever this comes up, everyone is just like, wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibibib Everything that is most wonderful and most problematic about her, all at once. Because Nicholas was this little wooden articulated doll that more like to use to talk to kids. It was about eight inches high. And when she was in the reading room, if a young child was acting shy, perhaps because their English wasn't very good yet.
它会破坏整个故事。就像它会让整个故事戛然而止一样。我完全明白你的意思，我完全经历过。是的，是的，这是因为每当这件事被提起时，每个人都像……关于她的一切最美妙也最令人困扰的地方，同时出现。因为尼古拉斯是一个小木制关节玩偶，摩尔喜欢用它来和孩子们交谈。它大约八英寸高。当她在阅览室时，如果一个年幼的孩子表现得很害羞，也许是因为他们的英语还不是很好，
And she wanted to bring them out of their shell. She would pull this doll out of her handbag and basically say, I want to introduce you to Nicholas. That's so sweet. I actually kind of like that sort of Mr. Rogers kind of quality to it. So was Nicholas like, did Nicholas have a certain personality or was he just kind of in care of more? Yeah. So Nicholas apparently was a little Dutch boy with like a little Dutch boy outfit Which I which I kind of suspect was a nod to the idea that so many of the children using the reading room were immigrants But more importantly, she would tell the children that Nicholas came alive at night and had access to this kind of Magical world hiding just behind this one and so the idea was that you might think you were in a normal old boring room, but when Nicholas showed up, he would help reveal the magic all around you. Right. I mean, that just reminds me of all the types of books that she was really fond of.
而她想让他们走出自己的壳。她会从手提包里拿出这个玩偶，基本上说，我想把你介绍给尼古拉斯。太甜了。我其实有点喜欢那种罗杰斯先生式的品质。那么尼古拉斯有某种个性吗？还是他只是由摩尔照顾？是的。所以尼古拉斯显然是一个穿着荷兰小男孩服装的荷兰小男孩，我怀疑这是在向阅览室里许多使用阅览室的孩子是移民这一事实致意。但更重要的是，她会告诉孩子们尼古拉斯在晚上会活过来，并且可以进入这个隐藏在这一层背后的神奇世界。所以这个想法是，你可能以为你在一个普通、无聊的房间里，但当尼古拉斯出现时，他会帮助揭示你周围的魔法。对。我的意思是，这让我想起了她真正喜欢的那些书。
I mean, she always liked those escapist stories. Right. Very once upon a time, none of that boring, bank street stuff. Right. Right. No garbage trucks. No city problems, yeah. Right, where you just get the child to the light in the mere room itself. No, you know, so the whole point of Nicholas was to propel the child into these flights of imagination
我的意思是，她一直喜欢那些逃避现实的故事。对。非常“很久很久以前”，没有那些无聊的银行街的东西。对。对。没有垃圾车。没有城市问题，是的。对，你只是让孩子在房间本身就感到愉悦。没有，你知道，所以尼古拉斯的全部意义在于推动孩子进入这些想象的飞翔，
that would take them beyond here and now into these magical nighttime realms. I mean, that all seems pretty wonderful. That seems like a good librarian thing to do. You mentioned that it was kind of, it represented kind of the problematic way in which she operated. How did it manage to do that? Yeah. So the problem is that, as with so many things related to Anne Carole Moore, there is a
带他们超越此时此地，进入这些神奇的夜间领域。我的意思是，这一切看起来都很美妙。这看起来像是一件好的图书管理员该做的事。你提到它有点，它代表了她运作方式中那种有问题的一面。它是怎么做到这一点的？是的。所以问题在于，正如与安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔相关的许多事情一样，有一个
dark side to Nicholas Nickerbacher. And in this case, it's that Nicholas' life was not restricted to the confines of the reading room. Dan Coise was telling me that apparently, after a while, people started noticing that Moore was carrying Nicholas around with her almost all the time. I can only speculate as to what people thought about. And Carol Moore carrying around Nicholas Nicarbacher. There are photos of her just like out in the park in Bright Park.
尼古拉斯·尼克巴克的阴暗面。在这种情况下，尼古拉斯的生活并不局限于阅览室。丹·科伊斯告诉我，显然过了一段时间，人们开始注意到摩尔几乎一直带着尼古拉斯。我只能猜测人们对安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔带着尼古拉斯·尼克巴克有什么想法。有照片显示她就像在布莱恩特公园里一样。
I assume just carrying Nicholas the doll under her arm. And I don't know if it was her way of connecting to children or if she just had some kind of weird-ass fixation. to children, or if she just had some kind of weird-ass fixation. I mean, I can see, you know, his concern, or maybe other people's concern, but like a generous reading of this is like, you know, she had a cool companion, she had a doll, she talked to kids, it seems like it seems okay to me so far. Okay, fair enough, but keep in mind that walking around the park with the doll was just like the tip of the iceberg.
我假设只是把尼古拉斯玩偶夹在腋下。我不知道这是她与孩子联系的方式，还是她只是有一种奇怪的执念。我的意思是，我能理解他的担忧，或者也许是其他人的担忧，但对这件事的一种宽容解读是，你知道，她有一个很酷的伙伴，她有一个玩偶，她和孩子们交谈，到目前为止对我来说似乎还可以。好吧，有道理，但请记住，带着玩偶在公园里走动只是冰山一角。
Because apparently she would also host these dinner parties. And when everyone sat down for dinner, Nicholas would be seated at the table, like with his own spot and his own play setting and everything. And at like at a dinner party where you're supposed to talk to Nicholas, is that part of the deal?
因为显然她还会举办这些晚宴。当每个人坐下来吃晚饭时，尼古拉斯会坐在桌边，就像有他自己的位置和餐具一样。在晚宴上，你必须和尼古拉斯交谈，这是交易的一部分吗？
Yeah, I think so. And even Jan Pinbarrow, who of everyone I talked to for this story is probably the most ardent defender of Anchor Elmore, admitted that this could be a challenge for more friends and colleagues. It's been said that some people didn't like Nicholas because she did, I think, sometimes hide behind him. Like, if she didn't want to give someone bad news She might say oh Nicholas doesn't like that You know so I can imagine how that would great on a person Me too Yeah, so you mean you can see where this is going right because like when Nicholas disapproved of something
是的，我想是这样。甚至连简·平巴罗（Jan Pinbarrow）——我在这个故事中采访的所有人中，她可能是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔最热心的捍卫者——也承认这对摩尔的朋友和同事来说可能是一个挑战。据说有些人不喜欢尼古拉斯，因为她确实，我想，有时躲在他身后。比如，如果她不想给某人坏消息，她可能会说“哦，尼古拉斯不喜欢那样”。你知道，所以我可以想象这会让人多么恼火。我也是。是的，所以你的意思是你可以看出事情的发展方向，对吧？因为当尼古拉斯不赞成某事时，
Whether it was like at a party or a work meeting, you were still expected to respond and apologize or whatever, because this is Ann Carole Moore. Remember, she is this titan of children's books. Right. And your career was in her hands. So you would just kind of be stuck talking to this doll.
无论是在聚会上还是在工作会议上，你仍然被期望做出回应并道歉什么的，因为这是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔。记住，她是儿童读物界的泰斗。对。而你的职业生涯掌握在她手中。所以你只能被困在那里和这个玩偶说话。
My hunch is that everyone talked about Nicholas Nicarbacher when Anne Carrollmore wasn't around, and when Anne Carrollmore was around, everyone was like, oh, hey, hi, Nicholas, how are you? You know, she, she wielded just a remarkable amount of power inside the library. And so, what would you do if you were in that situation and the person you depended on carrying around a wooden doll? You would be like, hey, Nicholas, good to see you. Have a seat at the table, can I get you a cup of tea? And by some point, according to Jolapour, the whole conceit was taken so far that Nicholas actually had his own letterhead.
我的直觉是，当安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔不在时，每个人都在谈论尼古拉斯·尼克巴克；而当安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔在场时，每个人都说：“哦，嘿，嗨，尼古拉斯，你好吗？”你知道，她在图书馆内部拥有相当大的权力。所以，如果你处于那种境地，而你所依赖的人带着一个木制玩偶，你会怎么做？你会说：“嘿，尼古拉斯，很高兴见到你。请坐，我能给你倒杯茶吗？”根据乔拉普尔的说法，在某种程度上，整个构想被推得太远了，以至于尼古拉斯实际上有了自己的信笺。
And more would write letters to children's book authors and editors in the voice of the doll. Oh my. And they would be signed Nicholas with a return address on the back of the envelope flap that said Nicholas Nickervacher and then the address of the central branch of the New York Public Library.
摩尔会以玩偶的声音给儿童读物作者和编辑写信。天哪。而且它们会签上“尼古拉斯”，信封背面有一个回信地址，上面写着“尼古拉斯·尼克巴克”，然后是纽约公共图书馆中心分馆的地址。
So he lives at the library. Right, lives at the library. Comes the library, nine at the library. Sure, Why not? That's when he writes his letters. Yeah. That's when he gets his best work done. Exactly. That is that is that is when he's at home. And but so did the children's, you know, book editors and authors, did they write back to Nicholas? Was that like part of the deal of this fantasy? to Nicholas was that like part of the deal of this fantasy? You know, I don't know. I do know that very frequently authors would send him their
所以他住在图书馆。对，住在图书馆。来图书馆，在图书馆过夜。当然，为什么不呢？那是他写信的时候。是的。那是他完成最好工作的时候。没错。那就是，那就是他感到自在的时候。但是，那么儿童读物的编辑和作者们，他们会回信给尼古拉斯吗？那是这种幻想的一部分吗？你知道，我不知道。我确实知道，作者们经常会通过安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔向他表达
warm regards by way of Ankeral Moore. Like, please tell Nicholas, I say hello, because it was just understood that more and Nicholas were like a package deal. Yeah, that makes sense. But you know, despite the creep factor, give a mind that like, you know, kids also wrote to Nicholas. And some of the correspondence and gifts Nicholas received from adults also suggested a lot of people saw Nicholas as this benign or even kind of benevolent presence. So for example, the author of Billy Goat's Gruff made Ankerlmore a miniature version of her first book for Nicholas to carry around. Beatrix Potter sent her these little hand-drawn postcards to picked Peter Rabbit and Nicholas together, almost as if they were friends.
亲切的问候。比如，请告诉尼古拉斯我向他问好，因为大家都默认摩尔和尼古拉斯是一个整体。是的，这说得通。但你知道，尽管有令人毛骨悚然的因素，但请记住，孩子们也会写信给尼古拉斯。尼古拉斯从成年人那里收到的一些信件和礼物也表明，许多人认为尼古拉斯是一个良性的，甚至是仁慈的存在。例如，《三只公山羊格鲁夫》的作者为尼古拉斯制作了一个她第一本书的微型版本，让他随身携带。碧翠丝·波特寄给她这些手绘明信片，描绘了彼得兔和尼古拉斯在一起，就好像他们是朋友一样。
And according to Jan, one of the employees from the library was like this Russian emigrate, and she apparently gave Nicholas like a Faberier egg. Whoa. Like a real Faberier with like gemstones in it type of Faberier egg. Yeah, well, she said there was a gem inside. So I can I go with at least a yes, a Faberier egg with one gem. But the point is that in the end, you can make an argument that Nicholas Nicobock is reigned in the balance, you know, didn't more good than harm. And as was so much of what Ann Caramore did, it's a close call. Well, I mean, creating a character to make kids comfortable in the library is
根据简的说法，图书馆的一名员工是一位俄罗斯移民，她显然给了尼古拉斯一个法贝热彩蛋。哇。就像那种带有宝石的真正的法贝热彩蛋。是的，好吧，她说里面有一颗宝石。所以我至少可以同意，是的，一个带有一颗宝石的法贝热彩蛋。但重点是，最终，你可以争辩说尼古拉斯·尼克巴克的统治在平衡中，你知道，利大于弊。正如安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔所做的大部分事情一样，这是一个很难判断的问题。好吧，我的意思是，创造一个角色让孩子们在图书馆感到舒适是
totally nice and joyful thing to do. Making her employees, adult employees, talk to it is a little odd, but you know, I hope it was good on balance. I mean, I hope for everyone's sake, it was good on balance. So, so Nicholas Nicarbocker as an extension of Anne Carol Moore's personality, did she just take it with her when she retired? Or did it sort of like live on in the libraries? It's like mascot excellent question because this is where this whole weird side story kind of climaxes Which is when the elaborately rendered fiction of Nicholas collides with the reality Okay, you know, he's just a doll and
一件完全美好和快乐的事情。让她的员工，成年员工，和它交谈有点奇怪，但你知道，我希望它在平衡中是好的。我的意思是，我希望为了每个人的利益，它在平衡中是好的。那么，那么尼古拉斯·尼克巴克作为安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔个性的延伸，她退休时把它带走了吗？还是它在图书馆里活了下来？就像吉祥物一样。很好的问题，因为这就是整个奇怪的侧面故事达到高潮的地方，也就是尼古拉斯精心渲染的虚构与现实发生碰撞的时候。好吧，你知道，他只是一个玩偶，
Dolls can be lost. Oh, no. It was actually an employee of the library who was writing with Anne Carrollmore in a taxi cab, and she was in charge of minding Nicholas and left it in the cab. Oh, I mean, I don't mean to disparage anyone's character, but I'm suspecting foul play here. I mean, if I was the indulged employee of Anne Carole Moore, and I was in charge of the doll who I had to talk to and serve cookies to, I might be inclined to leave it in a cab too. Yeah, you know, we'll never know. I'll give them the benefit of the doubt and say they're innocent, but I am sure many of Moore's colleagues secretly cheered when this happened.
玩偶可能会丢失。哦，不。实际上是图书馆的一名员工在出租车里和安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔一起，她负责照顾尼古拉斯，结果把它落在了出租车里。哦，我的意思是，我不是要诋毁任何人的品格，但我怀疑这里有猫腻。我的意思是，如果我是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的宠儿，而我负责照顾那个我必须与之交谈并提供饼干的玩偶，我也可能会倾向于把它留在出租车里。是的，你知道，我们永远不会知道。我会给他们无罪推定，说他们是无辜的，但我敢肯定，当这件事发生时，摩尔的许多同事都在暗自欢呼。
But then a little while later, apparently Moore just went out and found a new little wooden Dutch boy. And basically said, like, oh, good news everyone, Nicholas is back. Oh my goodness, the, good news, everyone. Nicholas is back. Oh my goodness. Oh, the rain of Nicholas keeps going. Yeah, and so much like Anne Carroll more herself,
但后来过了一会儿，显然摩尔只是出去找了一个新的小木制荷兰男孩。基本上说，“哦，大家有个好消息，尼古拉斯回来了。”我的天哪，“大家有个好消息，尼古拉斯回来了。”我的天哪。哦，尼古拉斯的统治还在继续。是的，就像安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔本人一样，
Nicholas, Nickerbacher refused to retire. Oh, that's so good. Oh, that's so fascinating. I can totally see why that's in belong in the story because I would be totally preoccupied with it. Today, Nickerbacher and many of the other figures in the story are getting to live a strange afterlife thanks in part to this week's experts. Go to your local library and browse the children's section and you'll come across dueling picture books whose author's names, if you've been
尼古拉斯·尼克巴克拒绝退休。哦，那太好了。哦，那太迷人了。我完全明白为什么它属于这个故事，因为我会完全被它占据。今天，尼克巴克和故事中的许多其他人物正在过着一种奇怪的来世，这在一定程度上要归功于本周的专家。去你当地的图书馆浏览儿童区，你会遇到两本对决的图画书，如果你一直
paying attention, will look familiar. Miss Moore thought otherwise how Anne-Karol Moore created libraries for children is written by Jan Pinbro and the important thing about Margaret Wise Brown is by Mac Barnett. Two books have two very different takes on what Anne-Karol Moore was really up to in our reading room. Whether she would have recommended either of them for purchase by expert, we will never know, but a good library and a good bookstore should carry them both. Thanks to all of our experts in today's story, if you're looking for a adult book on brown, check out Leonard Marcus's
关注的话，作者的名字会看起来很熟悉。《摩尔小姐另有想法：安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔如何为儿童创建图书馆》由简·平布罗撰写，《关于玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗的重要事情》由麦克·巴内特撰写。两本书对安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔在我们的阅览室里到底在做什么有非常不同的看法。她是否会推荐购买其中任何一本，我们永远不会知道，但好的图书馆和好的书店应该两者兼备。感谢今天故事中的所有专家，如果你正在寻找一本关于布朗的成人书籍，请查看伦纳德·马库斯的
Margaret Wise Brown Awakened by the Moon. Thanks also to Satellare, whose voice we did not get to include in this story, but whose book Children's Literature from Esop to Harry Potter is a great guide to the deeper history of Kislet. We also recommend Dan Quistis' podcast, it's all about parenting, it's called Mom and Dad, or Fighting, you will learn a thing or two about kids' books in there too. And finally, be sure to listen to Joly Poor's new podcast, it's called The Last Archive, it traces the history of evidence,
《玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗：被月亮唤醒》。还要感谢萨特拉尔，我们没能把她的声音包含在这个故事中，但她的书《从伊索到哈利·波特的儿童文学》是了解儿童文学更深层历史的绝佳指南。我们还推荐丹·奎斯特的播客，它是关于育儿的，叫《妈妈和爸爸在吵架》，你也会在那里学到一两件关于儿童读物的事情。最后，一定要听听乔利·波尔的新播客，它叫《最后的档案》，它追溯了证据、
proof, and knowledge, it is fascinating, it is funny, it is really weird, in a great way, I just really enjoy it. Well, it links to all that and more on the website. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Joe Rosenberg with many assists by Vivian Le. Bryson Barnes Mixed The Show, Music by Sean Rial. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colestetti is the digital director, thrice the team. Is Emmett Fitzgerald, Katie Mangle, Chris Barube, Abby Madon, Christopher Johnson, Sophia Glasgow, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and
证明和知识的历史，它很迷人，很有趣，而且以一种很棒的方式非常奇怪，我真的很喜欢它。好吧，网站上有所有这些以及更多的链接。《99%隐形》本周由乔·罗森伯格制作，薇薇安·勒提供了许多帮助。布莱森·巴恩斯混音，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。我们的高级制作人是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·科莱斯蒂是数字总监，团队成员还有埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、凯蒂·曼格尔、克里斯·巴鲁贝、艾比·马登、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、索菲亚·格拉斯哥和我，罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，
produced on Radio Row, which is distributed in multiple locations and houses and apartments all across North America, but in our hearts will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX. Our fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Fun is all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and show it at 99PI.
在“广播街”制作，它分布在北美各地的多个地点、房屋和公寓中，但在我们心中，它永远在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的RadioTopia的创始成员。我们是一个由世界上最创新的、听众支持的、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。乐趣尽在radiotopia.fm。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI。
Org, or on Instagram and read it too. For our true home on the internet is 99pi.org. Radio tilp you. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上。因为我们在互联网上的真正家园是99pi.org。RadioTopia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。